[Music]
creativity is about a kind of an
adrenaline
of balancing often conflicting and
contradictory ideas
that allows you to deliver them la
[Music]
creativity
it's definitely you know having a level
of freedom where you know
you can make a mistake you have to be a
bit fearless
when you want to do something different
and you just know
that you are in the right energy
to get the right understanding of ideas
and colors and textures
and that is what i need to do a costume
design
[Music]
i think great costume design is not
about wow look at the costumes look at
the costumes
it is about creating this world and this
collaboration
where everything adds up to a whole
costume design has
of course a lot to do with with clothes
and with
fashion but much more with emotions
you know one of my favorite parts of
doing fittings with actors is
if you can see how they respond to the
costume or it changes
anything in their pattern that helps
shift them into that character
personally
so my costume design of course started
with the research with going through all
the dynasties
i get an idea what was there
so the creative process you know kind of
has these ebbs and flows and as you
as you start discovering things and
start doing your research
it kind of narrows in on like okay this
is the direction i'm gonna
go this is what's gonna be most
appealing and most true to the story
part of my work is
being open to the serendipity of a
moment and recognizing what is good
and running with that luckily on almost
every project there are moments of many
moments
where you just go oh i get it oh
it's working i know where i'm going with
mulan
i knew that i wanted to have a huge
opening scene with more volume with more
shape and just bigger i did not do a
period movie
i did a fantasy movie
illustration the liberty pinocchio
if you look at stuff with your naked eye
it translates completely different
from color and into black and white so
on this particular project it was kind
of funneling these images
and figuring out what you know what
would complement
the environment that we would be in what
would complement the actors and what
would complement the story
[Music]
costing design is growing in a direction
where it gets more and more attention
future costume design is very broad
for me personally i'm kind of very old
school in a lot of ways
so i do think there's massive amounts of
technology out there
that are really useful and helpful to us
as costume designers and as filmmakers
and i just think you have to properly
pick and choose how you apply it to your
script
a lot of the world we work in is getting
digital
but you know costume department does
come back
primarily to hands on the table sewing
and i think one of the challenges moving
forward is is
what is the blend of digital
in a good way into our world
you